Facebook announcing a new digital
currency and aims to make it as easy to
send money around the world as it is to
send a photo facebook wants to have a
friend your wallet we are fully
committed to working with regulators
here and around the world David Marcus
is a Facebook executive who was called
to testify in to congressional hearings
this week after releasing a white paper
last month for a new digital currency
satoshi nakamoto is the pseudonym of a
mysterious software developer who
released a paper describing the
cryptocurrency Bitcoin an obscure
mailing list in 2008 and then
disappeared two years later so we are
discussing a currency controlled by an
undemocratic li.selected coalition of
largely massive corporations this is not
Silicon Valley Facebook now wants to
control the money like a toddler who has
gotten his hands with a book of matches
what could possibly go wrong
Satoshi Nakamoto created a decentralized
software Network then no government
agency has the authority to regulate our
control we've got the Treasury the
Federal Reserve the SEC the FDIC the OCC
CFPB the NCUA the CFTC the FHFA which of
all of these regulators would have a
piece of creating the rules of the road
do you believe currency is a public good
congresswoman I believe that sovereign
currencies are sovereign you believe
secrets should be a public good
congresswoman again we will work with
all of the regulators and and address
all concerns and the regulators will
definitely I'll take that as a no I
should take that doesn't know it is not
for me to decide Congress okay I'll take
that as enough in the end Congress has a
great deal of power but one of the most
important differences between Facebook's
Libra and Bitcoin is that it can never
make Satoshi Nakamoto sit in that chair
takes a breathtaking
of arrogance a breathtaking amount of
arrogance to look at that track record
and thing you know real